>> President Trump: CARAVAN
AFTER CARAVAN IS FORMING
UNVENTED ILLEGAL ALIENS, TRYING
TO FLOOD INTO OUR COUNTRY ON
YOUR DOLLAR, OVERWHELMING OUR
SCHOOLS, DEPLETING YOUR
RESOURCES, AND ENDANGERING YOUR
COMMUNITIES.
>> THEY ARE TELLING YOU THE
EXISTENTIAL THREAT TO AMERICA AS
A BUNCH OF POOR REFUGEES A
THOUSAND MILES AWAY.
THEY ARE EVEN TAKING OUR BRAVE
TROOPS AWAY FROM THEIR FAMILIES.
>> Bret: THERE'S THE A
BACK-AND-FORTH ON THE CAMPAIGN
TRAIL.
THE PRESIDENT IS FINISHING THIS
CAMPAIGN BLITZ IN WEST VIRGINIA,
INDIANAPOLIS, MONTANA,
PENSACOLA, FLORIDA TOMORROW,
GEORGIA, TENNESSEE TOMORROW,
OHIO, INDIANA, AND MISSOURI ON
MONDAY.
HE'S ALSO RIDING A WAVE OF GOOD
ECONOMIC MOVES.
>> President Trump: AMERICA
HAS THE BEST ECONOMIC HISTORY
AND OUR COUNTRY AND WE WANT TO
KEEP IT THAT WAY.
IN THE LAST MONTH ALONE, WE
ADDED, AND THIS JUST CAME OUT A
FEW HOURS AGO, 250,000 JOBS.
[CHEERS AND APPLAUSE]
THAT'S IN THE MONTH OF OCTOBER,
BY THE WAY.
FOR ONE MONTH.
AND NEARLY HALF A MILLION
AMERICANS RETURNED TO THE
WORKFORCE.
WE CREATED 4.5 MILLION NEW JOBS
SINCE THE ELECTION.
>> Bret: SO THAT OCTOBER JOBS
REPORT WAS STELLAR AND EVEN
CRITICS OF THE PRESIDENT SAY IT
WAS PRETTY GOOD.
250,000 JOBS, 3.7     3.7     37
250,000 JOBS, 3.7     3.7     3P
250,000 JOBS, 3.7     3.7     3E
250,000 JOBS, 3.7     3.7     3T
250,000 JOBS, 3.7     3.7     3L
250,000 JOBS, 3.7     3.7     3W
FOR THE RATE, A REAL BUMP IN
CONSUMER CONFIDENCE AN AVERAGE
OF ALL OF HOURLY EARNINGS ARE UP
WHICH IS A BIG DEAL AS WELL.
WITH ALL OF THAT, LET'S BRING IN
OUR PANEL.
JOSH CRUSH HOUR, MOLLIE
HEMINGWAY, AND CHARLES LANE.
OKAY JOSH, WE HAVEN'T HEARD THAT
MUCH, A TON, ABOUT THE ECONOMY
ON THE TRAIL.
THE JOBS NUMBER IS CLEARLY A
CLOSING ARGUMENT FOR SOME
REPUBLICANS.
>> THAT'S PART OF THE PROBLEM
FROM THE WHITE HOUSE, YOU DON'T
HEAR THE PRESIDENT TALKING THAT
MUCH ABOUT THE ECONOMY AS HE IS
ABOUT IMMIGRATION.
IN THE RED STATES, MISSOURI,
INDIANA, WEST VIRGINIA,
IMMIGRATION IS A PRETTY POTENT
ISSUE.
BUT WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE HOUSE
MAP AND YOU LOOK AT HOW MANY
SEATS COULD END UP FLIPPING IN
SUBURBAN AREAS THAT ARE JUST A
LITTLE UNCOMFORTABLE WITH THE
ANTI-IMMIGRATION OR ANTI-ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION RHETORIC.
THERE ARE A LOT OF STRATEGISTS
WONDERING WHY PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
NOT TALKING ABOUT THE GOOD
ECONOMIC NEWS AND FOCUSING ON
IMMIGRATION.
>> AS THEY NOTED, PEOPLE NOTICE
WHEN THE ECONOMY IS BAD.
I THINK THE MAIN SIGNIFICANCE OF
THE ECONOMY BEING SO GOOD AND IT
HAS BEEN GOOD FOR A WHILE NOW IS
IT HAS TEMPER THAT DESIRE TO
THROW THE BUMS OUT OR COMPLETELY
CHANGE THE MANAGEMENT OF THE
COUNTRY.
A LOT OF IT IS DIRECTLY TIED TO
REPUBLICAN POLICIES, WHETHER
IT'S TAX CUTS OR REGULATORY
PULLBACK OR ANY OF THE OTHER
THINGS THAT THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION AND REPUBLICANS
IN CONGRESS HAVE DONE.
AND ARE PARTICULARLY NOTEWORTHY
I THINK IS THE INCREASE IN
HOURLY WAGES.
OFTEN TIMES WE HAD GOOD ECONOMIC
NEWS WHERE IT SEEMS TO BENEFIT
THE WEALTHY AND NOT NECESSARILY
TRICKLE DOWN.
THIS IS GOOD FOR EMPLOYEES AND
PEOPLE THROUGHOUT THE ECONOMIC.
>> Bret: SPEAKING OF THE
IMMIGRATION ISSUE, THE INCUMBENT
DEMOCRAT SPEAKING ABOUT
SUPPORTING PRESIDENT TRUMP.
>> STOPPED THEM AT THE BORDER.
>> THEN WHAT DO YOU DO?
>> IF THE PRESIDENT HAS TO USE
EVERY TOOL AT HIS DISPOSAL AND I
100% BACK HIM UP ON THAT.
WHETHER IT'S TURNING HIM BACK
BECAUSE WE ARE NOT EQUIPPED TO
HANDLE THAT MANY ASYLUM CLAIMS
INTO OUR SYSTEM -- >> IF YOU ARE
FOR IT, PROVE IT.
TAKE YOUR NAME OFF DIANNE
FEINSTEIN'S OPEN BORDERS BILL.
CLAIRE McCASKILL IS SPONSORING
A BILL AND HAS BEEN FOR MONTHS.
SO PUT YOUR MONEY WHERE THEIR YU
SO PUT YOUR MONEY WHERE THEIR YR
MOUTH IS AND TAKE YOUR NAME OFF.
WE WANT THE REPUBLICANS CALL IT
THE OPEN BORDER BILL, IT'S
ACTUALLY NOT CALLED THAT BUT IT
IS A BILL THAT EVERY DEMOCRAT
SIGNED ONTO AND IT HAS THIS
THING THAT SAYS YOU CAN'T ARREST
ANYONE WITHIN 100 MILES OF THE
BORDER, FOR ANYTHING IF THEY ARE
AN ILLEGAL ALIEN.
>> MY REACTION TO A LOT OF THE
THINGS A PRESIDENT HAS BEEN
SAYING OVER THE LAST WEEK AS HE
IS PLAYING ON PEOPLE'S FEARS,
PARTICULARLY WITH RESPECT TO
THIS CARAVAN WHICH WILL PROBABLY
PETER OUT LONG BEFORE IT GETS TO
THE BORDER.
HAVING SAID THAT, HE'S NOT DOING
IT BY ACCIDENT, HE'S DOING IT
BECAUSE OF FEARS EXIST.
CLAIRE McCASKILL'S INTERVIEW
WITH YOU EPITOMIZES THAT
PERFECTLY.
I BELIEVE JOE DONNELLY IS SAYING
SIMILAR THINGS IN INDIANA AND HE
UNDERSTANDS THAT IN RED STATES
HE HAS THE DEMOCRATS ON THE
DEFENSIVE.
WITH RESPECT TO THAT BILL, IT
ILLUSTRATES THE DEMOCRATS AND
ABILITY SO FAR TO COME UP WITH A
POPULAR MESSAGE REGARDING
IMMIGRATION THAT SPEAKS ABOUT
THE ISSUE IN A WAY THAT'S BOTH
POSITIVE TOWARD IMMIGRATION AND
CAPABLE OF GAINING A MAJORITY.
INSTEAD YOU HAVE PEOPLE LIKE
CLAIRE McCASKILL RUNNING AWAY
FROM THE NATIONAL PARTY AND THE
WASHINGTON-BASED PARTY AND THEY
ARE MESSAGE.
IF THERE IS ANY HOPE OR SAVING
GRACE FOR THAT WITHIN IT FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, IT HAS TO DO WITH
JOSH'S POINT ABOUT THE SUBURBS.
I THINK THE RED-HOT STUFF THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS PRESENTING ON
IMMIGRATION MAY BE TURNING OFF
MODERATE REPUBLICANS AND WOMEN
IN THOSE SUBURBAN DISTRICTS THAT
THEY NEED TO HOLD.
>> Bret: WE WILL SEE AND WE
WILL SEE HOW MUCH THE ECONOMY
AND THE SPINAL JOBS REPORT MOVES
PEOPLE ONE WAY OR THE OTHER.
I WANT TO PUT UP THE POWER
RANKINGS.
IN THE SENATE, WE HAVE IT REALLY
THE SAME AS WE'VE HAD IT.
50 REPUBLICANS AND 45 DEMOCRATS.
THIS TAKES A LOOK AT THE RACES,
THE LIENS AND THE LIKELY THIS,
WE HAVE FIVE TOSS-UP RACES THERE
AND THAT WILL DESIGNED         D
AND THAT WILL DESIGNED         C
AND THAT WILL DESIGNED         E
AND THAT WILL DESIGNED         T
AND THAT WILL DESIGNED         O
AND THAT WILL DESIGNED         B
AND THAT WILL DESIGNED         L
AND THAT WILL DESIGNED         N
AND THAT WILL DESIGNED         E
POWER THERE.
NOW WE HAVE IT DOWN TO 29.
YOU NEED TO 18 FOR THE MAJORITY,
AND YOU NEED A FEW MORE TO PICK
UP ABOUT 17 TO GET THAT, IF YOU
COUNT THE LIKELY IS.
ALL RIGHT, RACE BY RACE, JOSH?
>> ONE OF THE HOUSE RACES I'M
LOOKING CLOSELY AT IS THE SIXTH
DISTRICT OF KENTUCKY.
IT'S A TRUMP DISTRICT, BUT THE
DEMOCRAT WHO IS A CELEBRATED
MILITARY VETERAN, AMY McGRATH,
IS RUNNING NECK AND NECK WITH
ANDY BARR.
THEY ARE WATCHING THE RACE
CLOSELY AND IT CLOSES EARLY SO
WE WILL KNOW THE RESULTS PRETTY
QUICKLY.
>> I CHOSE PENNSYLVANIA 16.
THIS IS THE KIND OF RACE THAT IF
DEMOCRATS WIN THIS IT WILL POINT
TO THEM HAVING A VERY GOOD
NIGHT.
THIS IS A DISTRICT THAT TRUMP
WON BY 20, AND SO DEPENDING ON
HOW THAT GOES IT MIGHT BE AN
INDICATOR OF THE WHOLE EVENING.
>> THOSE HOUSE POLLS ARE TOUGH.
IT DOESN'T SEEM LIKE IT REALLY
STICKS.
ALL THESE POLLS ARE 1-2 POINTS
AND COULD REALLY SWING EACH ONE
OF THESE RACES.
>> SINCE EVERYONE IS USING
NUMBER SIX, I HAVE THE SIXTH
DISTRICT TWO.
BUT PETER ROSKAM HAS BEEN THERE
SINCE 2006 AND REPUBLICANS HAVE
HELD THE SEAT SINCE 1972,
THROUGH ALL THE BLUE WAVES THAT
WENT TO AND FRO IN THAT TIME.
BUT HE'S IN THE RACE OF HIS LIFE
AGAINST DEMOCRAT SEAN KASTEN AND
THIS IS ONE OF THOSE RACES THAT
REALLY EPITOMIZES BECAUSE IT
WENT FOR HILLARY CLINTON.
THIS DISTRICT WENT FOR HILLARY
BY SEVEN POINTS LAST TIME
AROUND.
A LOT OF REPUBLICANS RETIRED
RATHER THAN RUN IN DISTRICTS
WHERE HILLARY ONE.
IF HE CAN'T PULL IT OFF THERE, I
THINK HE'S GOING TO SHOW THERE
IS A LONG NIGHT AHEAD FOR